foreign
[Music]
and welcome to another installment of
neriditsky's opening lab in this video
we're going to be tackling one of our
most daunting enemies to date we are
going to be demolishing the Danish
Gambit which has terrorized black
players for well over a century and a
half the Danish is one of the reasons
why a lot of players are afraid to play
uh E4 E5 and I think it's on par with
openings like the king's Gambit and even
with more reputable lines like the
scotch and the Italian it's a very very
serious opening it's not just a gimmicky
Gambit and you absolutely have to know a
lot of theory in order to avoid losing
the game quickly but worry not my
promise in these videos is one and the
same if you invest the requisite time if
you listen to the video carefully from
start to finish you will never have to
fear any of these openings again and the
Danish Gambit is no exception I will
show you in this video how to get a
reliably better and sometimes even
winning position against all of the
varieties of the Danish Gambit I will
show you how to neutralize White's
initiative and how to grab all of the
pawns that white offers and to get away
with it in style but we've got a lot of
work to do the Danish Gambit is very
theoretical and there's going to be a
lot of variations and ideas in this
video as usual I'll try to make it
palatable I'll try to make it as
entertaining as I can and remember you
can always pause set the position up on
your own board and you can do some
supplementary analysis if anything I say
is not clear or if there are any moves
that you're wondering about I will try
to be as always as comprehensive and
detailed as possible so without further
Ado let's jump in and let's start with a
little bit of context and definition
what is the Danish Gambit so the Danish
Gambit is defined by the following moves
white starts with E4 we respond with E5
and white enters the center game with D4
white actually gives up three of his
Pawns in Rapid succession this is the
first of them
and after black captures white can take
back on D4 but this is the center game
it's largely frowned upon and it will be
the subject of a separate video white
enters the Danish with the move C3
gambiting the First Pawn this very much
resembles a Smith Mora uh type idea
except against E5 rather than C5 and
after black accepts the pawn which by
the way is not forced and I will quickly
offer a practical alternative with the
move D5 in a little while but if black
takes the pawn then white is at a
further Crossroads white can recapture
on C3 this is not very common and yet
it's a line that has to be examined
carefully I will still lump this in the
general Danish Gambit category here
white only gambits one pawn and white
tries to play this much like a Smith
Moore bringing the bishop out to C4 in
the night out to F3 aiming for quick
development but the far more common and
traditional treatment of the Danish
gamut involves gambiting the second Pawn
with Bishop C4 wide bring brings out the
light skirt Bishop onto an optimal
Square staring at the F7 pawn and
offering black a second pawn and if
black takes it white finally recaptures
the pawn which started out on E5 and
ends up on B2 and in return for the two
sacrificed pawns white achieves a big
lead in development both of White's
Bishops are now developed onto optimal
squares the dark squared Bishop is
staring right down the barrel of that
long diagonal looking hungrily at that
G7 pawn and it's very clear even with an
untrained eye even if you don't know
anti-theory that white has clear and
evident compensation for the two
sacrificed Pawns in the form of better
central control white as a pawn in the
center black dozen and of course the
main draw the main appeal of the Danish
Gambit is White's big lead in
development which can lead to Rapid
Victory if black is not extremely well
versed in the ensuing Theory but again
don't worry all you will really have to
remember are the subsequent three or
four moves if you understand those moves
and their attendant ideas then you will
send the Danish Gambit right back where
he belongs and I don't know where I'm
going with this I don't know where it
belongs but um in any case let's jump
into the theory the Danish by the way
has been around uh for well over 150
years uh for a little bit of context it
was first played around 1850 in fact a
funny bit of trivia the first time the
move C3 was played was 1839 by none
other than Captain Evans the same guy
who developed the Evans Gambit in the
Italian so this guy uh was a Trailblazer
he was ahead of his time in that game
black ended up declining the Gambit with
Knight F6 the first time the traditional
Danish was played was not by uh a Danish
person it was by a Swede a guy named
Hans not Neiman Hans Linden in 1863 and
then shortly thereafter a lot of the top
players including zuker tort the world
champion Contender as well as Joseph
Henry Blackburn the top English player
they hopped aboard the Danish Gambit
train with great success and by the
early 1900s the Danish gamut had sort of
entered the regular rotation of a lot of
the top players who really saw in it an
opportunity uh to score tons of quick
victories uh remember that back then you
know people didn't study openings quite
as seriously there wasn't that as much
knowledge to go around and so Zucker
tort Blackburn steinits also played at
alkyne and others scored just countless
15 move and less victories in the Danish
Gambit Okay so
let's start from the beginning after
white plays the move C3 black is not
obliged to accept this first Gambit in
fact there is a very practical
alternative that I'm not going to
discuss at length I'm going to give you
the sort of tldr version of this
alternative but the appeal of having
this option in your back pocket and I'm
talking about the move D7 D5 counter
striking in the center is that it takes
the fun out of the Danish Gambit for
white I've talked about this earlier
Gambit players don't like it when you
decline their gambits and get sort of a
dry equal position they want something
fun they want to sacrifice uh one Pawn
or two pawns or three pieces or however
much they're trying to sacrifice and so
having an alternative like this in your
back pocket is a great idea the move D5
leads to an equal position but I
actually think black's practical chances
in the resulting position are more
comfortable so I'm going to give you a
sort of five minute elevator pitch of
the move D5 and then I'm going gonna
move on to my main recommendation if you
want actually want to get an objective
advantage against the Danish then you in
fact do have to accept the Gambit with
Pawn takes C3 so the point of D5 is
obvious black opens up the center and
counter strikes on the E4 Pawn White's
hand is essentially forcedier white has
to play e takes D5 although online tons
of people make other moves here which is
a little bit weird there's moves like E5
and Knight F3 which I won't even talk
about I want to remind you that there is
a link to a leeches study that contains
all of the variations that I'm about to
show and many others you can find that
in the description to this video so in
that file I'm more comprehensively
examine some of the third and fourth
rate options in a lot of positions and
this video I try to hit on the most
important points so the only semi-viable
alternative to e takes D5 is Queen takes
D4 and this is like an inferior version
of the center game black respect bonds
with Bishop B6 I think it's an
interesting way to support the D5 pawn
and after the trade on D5 black gets a
development Advantage the opportunity to
bring the Knight out with Tempo and
there's no question that white is
struggling for equality if white chases
the bishop away with C4 black is not
obliged to move it Queen E7 check gets
the queen out of uh the X-ray exerted by
its vis-a-vis checks the white king and
after Bishop B3 Bishop E6 black has a
great position and a furious initiative
something like Knight C3 the Knight
comes out the Rook comes to d8 and there
will be hell to pay because white is
just woefully underdeveloped here so uh
e takes D5 is the only serious option we
take back with the queen
now again white has a couple of second
rate options but virtually everybody
captures on T4 with the pawn we respond
to this with Knight to C6 and you might
find this position similar to an allop
and Sicilian it is very similar to an
alopin the difference of course being
that rather than upon on E7 there is now
a Pawn on C7 and I actually think this
makes White's uh play quite a bit more
Toothless the alopin uh as you might
know if you watch the Speed Run videos
is a very very legitimate opening so
Knight C6 hits the pawn on D4 white has
to defend it with the move Knight F3 and
here uh there is really only one move
that you have to remember if you're
looking at this for the first time you
might think that Bishop G4 is the most
reasonable move but in fact my
recommendation is to check on the other
side Bishop to B4 check with a very
straightforward idea after white covers
with the Knight we no longer have to
move the queen away from D5 because the
Knight is pinned so now we have a little
bit of time that we can use to to bring
our other pieces out now we play Bishop
G4 pinning the other night The Bishop's
kind of crisscrossing the Knight on both
sides we're threatening to capture the
Knight and capture the pawn on uh D4 so
if white plays a passive move like
Bishop E3 we absolutely take white up on
their offer we play Bishop takes F3 and
uh after something like GF Castle's
Queen side again we don't have to move
our Queen until black white plays A3 in
which case we do take the Knight on C3
White's King side is in shambles the D4
Pawn is weak and after something like A3
Pawn takes uh Bishop takes Pawn takes
Knight F6 white has uh just a terrible
position our rook's coming to E8 and
whites King has has no Safe Haven on
either side of the board so rewinding
back to this position Bishop E2 is
essentially forced and now uh we do a
slightly weird looking procedure that
basically forces an end game in which I
think black's chances are slightly
preferable even though the computer
evaluates the position as equal and this
might seem too good to be true and yet
this line is in fact virtually forced
this is why I'm deviating from my
standard procedure which is only to
recommend one line and I'm kind of
giving you this line uh in in the event
that you don't want uh you know to
engage in tons of theory or let's say
you're playing a bullet game and you
want to play something more practical
and easier to remember now we take the
Knight on F3 and we do that in order to
open up a square on C4 for the black
queen it may seem weird to give up the
bishop pair but notice what we're doing
here we're preventing light from Castle
in King's side that would be illegal we
are attacking the D4 pawn two different
ways but we're also attacking the Knight
on C3 so we're creating uh essentially
two threats at once and white has no
choice here but to liquidate and give up
the bishop pair with Bishop takes C6
check there are just no other moves the
only other move played with any kind of
regularity is Queen to B3 offer bring
the queen trade we are more than happy
to trade queens and we reach an end game
in which white is saddled with the
permanent weakness of the D4 Upon Our
pieces are very well developed and uh
most people who've had this position
slide into a really really bad position
very quickly for instance if White
Castles weak Castle Queen side and D5
may seem like a scary move because we
lose A7 but with the Queens off the
board we have nothing to fear we jump
into D4 with the Knight after Rook takes
A7 we get a liquidation followed by a
better end game for black we snap off
the bishop on F3 we take the Knight on
C3 the check is nothing to fear after B
takes C3 Knight takes D5 black has a
clearly better end game White's Pawn
structure is ruined the check is
innocuous and if white plays C4 we could
even throw in the move King to B8
forcing The Rook out of the seventh rank
then the Knight entrenches itself on B4
and black has a very pleasant position
this actually occurred in a high level
game between two strong email players
March and verochi all the way back in
Belgrade in 1989. so Queen B3 is nothing
to fear in the uh lee chess file I give
a couple of other options such as Bishop
B3 uh to which we respond Bishop takes
C3 we accept the sacrifice and white has
nothing to write home about here
and so the main move by a country mile
is to play Bishop takes C6 eliminating
the Knight now taking with the queen
here would be very short-sighted because
it would allow white to Castle and
that's exactly what white won so instead
we take back with the pawn we need to
maintain contact with the F1 Square in
order to prevent white from castling and
yet again we're essentially forcing
White's hand we're threatening Bishop
takes C3 move like Bishop D2 is bad for
several reasons one of which is that we
don't even have to take on D4 we just
castle queenside and rookie 8 is coming
with devastating effects so white
essentially has to trade Queens if they
know what's good for them we accept uh
the trade and we get this uh very
balanced end game in which both sides
have obvious detriments uh in their Pawn
structure of course we have the damaged
Queen Side Pawn structure as a result of
us taking back with a pawn but white is
saddled with a long-term weakness of
this isolated Pawn on D4 and I I'd also
point out that White's King is far are
from safe it's standing on a file that
can easily be accessed by black strokes
and a lot of games to reach this
position actually end up in a direct
attack against uh White's King so the
game is likely to continue Bishop E3 we
bring our Knight out to F6 and Black's
play here is really really easy we bring
our Rook over to E8 and if white is not
careful once again he can slide into a
really bad position very quickly for
instance if white moves the king away
from the pin we were threatening to take
the pawn on D4 we entrench our Knight in
the center we're trying to rectify our
Pawn structure after Knight takes D5
Pawn takes D5 if white plays Rook HD1
then he is already worse we take on C3
we move our Rook forward to D6 and that
attack I mentioned has become a reality
because the Rook is going to slide over
to F6 with check we're going to try to
send the king back over to E2 and then
we can use the pin against the bishop to
mount direct pressure against the bishop
or uh the pawn that's going to take its
place after we trade the Knight on D5
for the bishop so this line with D5 is
what I would call a takeout line it
basically guarantees a good solid
position and it takes all of the fun out
of the Danish Gambit for white and so
I've decided to dedicate a little bit of
time to it just so you have this line in
your back pocket if you want to play
something a little bit simpler so once
again
uh there's a lot more detail uh in the
uh study that you will find in the
description but hopefully this gives you
a a suitable General overview so once
again we play D5 counter striking in the
center after the trade on D5 the only
important moves to remember first of all
are Bishop B4 check we want to start
specifically with this move after Knight
C3 the other Bishop comes out so
remember that the queen is not hanging
and after Bishop E2 the second move to
remember is Bishop takes F3 seems
counter-intuitive but we're sinking our
teeth into the C4 Square this virtually
forces white to liquidate uh into the
end game that we reach after Bishop
takes E6 Now Pawn takes
to keep control over the F1 Square we
get this end game this end game is very
easy to play for black so that's uh the
takeout line with C5 now
let's get to the meat of the video let's
get to the big boy stuff and that would
be Pawn takes C3 so again Buckle in
because there's gonna be a lot of theory
here but I will try to emphasize the
moves that you really have to remember
and uh I will try to present this in a
relatively digestible manner but as I
said at the start don't hesitate to
pause the video don't hesitate to break
it down into multiple chunks opening
study is really tough uh I don't
sugarcoat that in these videos I just
try to give you the stuff that you need
to know in order to get good positions
so first of all we need to tackle Knight
takes C3 and this move is orders of
magnitude less common online than Bishop
C4 I'm talking something like I think
1.5 million games on leeches versus 7
million uh with Bishop C4 so you're a
lot less likely to face this move and
yet from an objective standpoint I
actually think Knight takes C3 might be
better than Bishop C4 so here it's very
important for us to develop our minor
pieces in the right order and what we
want to avoid is the tempting Knight F6
actually a terrible move because it
walks right into E5 this is what white
wants and the Knight doesn't have any
good squares it has to retreat back to
gain and then black is immediately in
huge trouble after Bishop C4 what we
want to play here is Bishop to C5 we
bring our Bishop out first kind of
violating the opening principle about
Knights before Bishops but in a lot of
these gambits uh General opening
principles go out the window because we
have more important things to attend to
we play the move Bishop C5 and we
quickly solidify the bishop with D6 so
we actually delay the development of the
knights because well the Knight on G8 is
very susceptible to this move E5 so we
want to prevent that move or at least
take the sting out of it before we bring
the king side Knight out so generally
white plays Bishop C4 there are no other
reasonable moves if white plays another
developing move like F3 this is very
likely to transpose back into the main
line because eventually White's gonna
have to bring this bishop out and there
are no logical squares other than C4 if
white makes a passive move like you know
Bishop to D3 then you can just develop
your pieces with Knight F6 and castles
and white has limited to no compensation
for the pawn so uh Bishop C4 is the only
serious option and you should notice
that this actually creates a tactical
threat white threatens to take on F7 and
then to Fork the king and the bishop uh
with Queen to D5 and so we have to
solidify the bishop with D6 so we defend
the bishop we open up a pathway for our
other bishop and we obviously render
Bishop takes F7 check useless we also
render Queen D5 useless because it
doesn't attack this bishop any longer
and we can simply defend the F7 Pawn
with Queen to E7 followed by bringing
the Knight out to F6 and so white uh
generally continues to develop with
Knight to F3 what's interesting is that
the only way for white to avoid a
clearly worse position uh is this
computer move Queen to B3 this doesn't
happen very often and yet it's a very
important move to know because it
creates a rather nasty threat of Bishop
takes F7 check and this is not the
easiest Pawn to defend generally the way
that you would want to do it is to go
Knight H6 but here clearly this move is
ineffective because white can snap that
Knight off the board so you might say
well let's go Queen E7 but the issue
with Queen E7 is that it runs into the
super nasty Knight D5 we're paying the
price here for not developing our
Knights and after Queen takes c492 the
position is wildly chaotic this is
exactly what we don't want this would
play into white sand so instead the move
that you have to remember is not Queen
E7 not Queen F6 but Queen to H4
absolutely crucial move that takes this
line completely out of commission we
create a counter threat on F2 guess what
two can play at that game and at first
sight this move may seem absurd because
white just takes on F7 with check but
extend this line one move further and
hopefully you're beginning to see that
it is white who's in serious trouble not
black white is completely overextended
we're attacking the F2 Pawn the bishop
on F7 is you know dangling by a single
thread it's only protected by the queen
and why does a hard time keeping
everything under control
G3 is the only move that has featured
with any sort of regularity online and
yet it loses the game on the spot
perhaps you can pause the video and
figure out where the queen should go and
why white is already losing after the
next move
and I'll take this opportunity to watch
you suffer and drink some water again
matter Style
so the answer of course is that the
queen slides back to F6 now is the time
and this is a simple Fork we're
attacking the bishop on F7 and we're
attacking the pawn on F2 why does no
choice but uh to move the bishop to take
the Knight Bishop E3 has been played uh
a staggering number of times here we can
obviously just uh take on F7 or take on
E3 and take on F7 white as no
compensation for the piece so Bishop
takes G8 leads to disaster after Queen
takes F2 check now we calmly recapture
the bishop on G8 we have not only an
extra Pawn but obviously a a completely
decisive attack against White's King uh
which we can uh further by bringing the
bishop out to G4 at the right moment now
after Knight G2 the right moment has not
been reached because we need to keep an
eye on the B7 Pawn so first we develop
our Knight and after white develops
their Bishop I don't see any other
reasonable moves we drop our Queen back
to F3 this is a very precise move going
after the rook and uh also setting up a
pin against the E2 Knight so the idea is
revealed if white moves The Rook away
the Knight jumps into D4 and black has a
just a completely winning position you
can follow up by bringing the bishop out
or continuing to chase the queen after
something like Queen D5 C6 so white can
also try the move King to C2 but now the
Knight jumps into B4 sending the king
back toward the first rank King can't go
to the first ring because white loses
The Rook with check so white actually
has to give away the queen now why does
Recapture Black's Queen with Rook hf1
but When the Smoke Clears you should see
that white will end up down in exchange
we give the queen up for The Rook we
Slide the king over to E8 and why I can
continue the tactics here with Knight to
D5 but yet again this is nothing to fear
because we're up so much material that
we can afford to give some of it back we
take on D2 white takes on C7 and
temporarily white has re-established
material equality but not for very long
because after we drop our Bishop back
the Knight is completely and utterly
helpless and we're gonna trap the Knight
with a variety of different techniques
we can play B6 Bishop B7 or we could
bring the bishop out to E6 and then
slide the king up to D7 and win the
Knight that way and if white tries
Shenanigans with Rook F7 we intercept
The Rook with the com Bishop D7 then
white is absolutely white is totally
helpless let's make a random move uh the
simplest option here is just to go King
C8 we're actually going to use our King
to trap the Knight on A8 but before we
go King B8 we're gonna move this bishop
out of the way Bishop to D Bishop to E6
and uh regardless of where the Rook
moves uh our King reaches B8 and White's
Knight is lost but all of these last
moves are pretty easy to find
uh the Crux here is to remember the move
Queen H4 that was a long line and yet
it's relatively forced so I decided to
go pretty deep uh in this very important
variation again you have to remember the
move Queen H4 you ignore the threat on
F7 and you pose a counter threat to the
F2 Pawn now that isn't the whole story
white of course can play the move G3 and
white should play the move G3 if he
knows what's good for for him but having
induced this weakness on the king side
we now return to F6 here black is sort
of stably up a pawn for absolutely no
compensation and the only important
thing to remember here uh after the move
F4 is this move Queen back to E7 so I
know it's a weird slightly computer-ish
Queen maneuver but hopefully all three
of these moves make sense we play Queen
H4 to attack F2 we drop our Queen back
to F6 to induce the move F4 and now we
drop our Queen again for a very simple
reason we're trying to stop the knight
from jumping into D5 and we're opening
up a more natural develop developing
Square for our Knight so with Knight D5
impossible white has to develop uh their
other pieces we do the same with
something like Knight F6 and a lot of
games online continued E5 now the pawn
is pinned so we can just exert more
pressure on it with the move Knight B to
D7 and white is already collapsing from
all sides remember that black is up a
pawn to begin with and now after d takes
C5 we win another pawn and if white
tries to go for Rapid development we
keep the e-file closed with the move E4
and we use that pawn as temporary cover
we use it to Castle kingside now Black's
King is completely out of the woods and
White's Bishop is very much in the woods
in fact it's trapped after E3 this is an
online game that we've been following
the leecha study goes on after this
moment but I think that's enough I think
you get the point so G3 walks into Queen
F6 then the queen shifts back to E7 and
black gets a great position according to
the engine the only way for white to
maintain a playable position is a move
that almost nobody online has played
you're never going to face this move
it's the move Queen C2 which I've given
an exclamation mark it's utterly
ultimately illogical because the whole
reason you brought your queen to B3 was
to put pressure on F7 now suddenly
you're moving the queen away from C2 so
I won't devote a lot of attention to
this move in this video I analyzed it in
Great depth uh in the PGN that's
attached in the description the only
thing I'll say is that the next move is
Queen to G4 there's some really really
cool play with the queen in this line
and largely we're using our Queen to
provoke weaknesses on White's King side
to make it difficult for white to
conduct the attack on the other side of
the board and after F3 Our Queen goes
back to H4 more weaknesses are induced
and then all the way back to d8 we're
saying guess what if you're not gonna be
on B3 then we don't have to keep our
Queen in the vicinity of the F7 Punt and
if black white goes back to B3 now we go
around to D7 so we defend the pawn this
way having induced all of these
weaknesses Our Queen finally retires on
D7 note that Bishop B5 does not win the
queen it actually loses a bunch of Tempe
uh to C6 and after Knight ge2 we can
finally focus on developing our pieces
White's position here is just on the
verge of collapse night A5 is threatened
Knight E5 is also a devastating threat
so even if white finds this uh crazy
computer move white is still facing a
pawn down for absolutely no compensation
so that
concludes our overview of Queen B3 now
let's get to the move you're going to
face a lot more often which is Knight F3
white continues to develop their pieces
and so we continue to develop hours
having prevented the move E5 we bring
our Knight out to F6 after White Castles
we do the same and essentially we are
just up upon for very very little
compensation white has a tiny bit of
compensation because he's got a little
bit of a lead in development but with
some more accurate and careful moves
we're able to completely neutralize this
lead in development importantly the move
E5 is never dangerous as long as we have
a Pawn on D6 it actually only plays into
Black's Hands by allowing a queen trade
we play D takes C5 and after the trade
of Queens white can create a one move
threat on F7
uh which we easy easily Parry with the
move Bishop to E6 and after the trade
white has a miserable task ahead of him
just a pawn down end game for uh no
compensation so instead most people play
Bishop G5 here and the only thing that
you should remember is to bring this
Knight out not to C6 but to D7 if you
understand what white wants then this
move should be uh very obvious white
wants to play Knight D5 and exert
pressure on the F6 Knight this is really
White's only asset in this position and
so we link the knights up to take the
sting out of the move Knight D5 if white
tries this move anyway then we can chase
the Knight with C6 that's the second
reason that we don't occupy the C6
square with the Knight we want to play
the move Pawn to C6 in order to fully
restrict the mobility of White's Knight
so if white plays a move like rookie one
then we take this opportunity to play C6
and the Knight never has another active
Prospect ever again I continued the line
here with E5 this leads to sort of a
mass trade and once again after Rook
takes C5 white is a pawn down in the end
game and to make matters worse there is
another very cute tactic in this
position that merely Builds on Black's
material advantage maybe you can pause
the video once again see if you can spot
this straightforward tactical shot you
should notice that the King on G1 The
Rook on E5 they're almost unforkable
squares and you can make them get to
forkable squares the bishop takes F2
check and after the Smoke Clears Knight
to G4 check looks like black is losing
the rook in return but you have to
calculate one step further it's the
bishop on C4 that is hanging this gives
black two extra pawns for absolutely no
compensation note that the Desperado
sack Bishop F7 actually makes things
worse because after Knight takes F7
we're also simultaneously uh defending
the row so that's just one uh sample
line in which white ends up with a
miserable end game so back to this
position after Knight bd7 in the file I
also analyze to move like Queen C2 which
we can meet uh with or no I analyzed
what else did I anal is rookie one I
looked at 95 C6 and some Alternatives uh
on on this move here I considered E5
once again but uh long story short black
is up upon there's absolutely no con
compensation and after something like
Queen C2 we go H6 we can strike at the
center with D5 and this is a practical
move because we're actually giving the
pawn away in order to reach a long
lasting initiative something that Gambit
players absolutely hate they hate to be
the ones that are fighting against the
initiative so for instance e takes C
takes white can play the move Rick ad1
we get our Queen up to D6 getting out of
the pin against the Knight and yes white
recaptures the pawn with Bishop F6 and
Bishop D5 but now we drop our Bishop
back we bring our other Bishop out we
have a bishop pair an initiative against
White's Queen and according to the
engine black has a very stable Advantage
so this is the way in which you
neutralize is the immediate recapture on
C3 so important points first of all you
need to remember the move Bishop C5 do
not bring either Knight out it's very
important to get this bishop and
solidify it with the move D6 and this is
done in order to take the sting out of
the move E5 which otherwise would be
very dangerous so I should also point
out that after Bishop C4 D6 uh the move
E5 does absolutely nothing but not for
the reason that you might think do not
take on E5 here that plays right into
White's hands and it walks into this
very nasty tactic Bishop takes F7
checking instead you can exploit the
undefended nature of White's Bishop you
can you can play a move like Knight C6
and just bring your pieces out or you
can initiate a cute tactic with Bishop
takes F2 check followed by Queen H4 and
then you recapture the bishop with uh
just an overwhelming Advantage so E5 is
never scary I analyzed it in a couple of
uh different positions I analyzed it
here but here you just take on E5 and
you can always bring your light squared
Bishop out to E6 at the right moment to
neutralize its counterpart so first
thing to remember is to play Bishop C5
and D6 the second thing to remember is
after white brings their Bishop out to
G5 you actually play Knight B to D7 yes
you're blocking your light squared
Bishop but it's a lot more important to
keep this Knight on F6 uh well well
defended and to make sure that White's
Knight is restricted after not a
well-timed C6 and the final uh takeaway
is that Queen to B3 which can catch an
unprepared player unawares is met with
Queen to H4 this move is going to win
you some games because I'm almost
certain that people are going to
excitedly take on F7 and say what are
you doing you don't know what you're
doing after Queen F6 turns out that
White's the one who doesn't know what
they're doing because you're gonna win
F2 with a devastating attack and so that
means it is time for us to move on uh to
the traditional Danish Gambit with
Bishop C4 and it'll turn out that this
is quite a bit easier to master than
Knight takes C3 the line that I have
come up with is not only rare but I
think it's objectively best and if white
does not respond with filigree Precision
you're actually going to get a winning
position out of the opening so I'm super
super excited to be sharing this line
you start by accepting the second
sacrifice and there's quite a bit of
misinformation in this position when I
was a kid
my first coach shared with me a piece of
wisdom that's often considered to be
kind of a given which is that the best
way to neutralize the Danish is to play
this move D5 in this position
sacrificing the pawn back in order to
open up a diagonal for Black's bishop
and the wisdom goes that after Bishop
takes D5 you're supposed to go Knight F6
you sacrifice the second Pawn back as
well and here there is a little bit of
tactics King takes F7 Queen takes the
eight you win the queen back with a
bishop B4 check white drops the queen
back to D2 to get a piece for it and uh
you reach this end game but when I
started looking at this end game with
the computer I found the wax position is
actually really really unpleasant I
think white is better from a practical
standpoint and even if he wasn't we
don't want to fight the Danish Gambit
from a position of weakness we want to
fight it from the position of strength
we don't want to just give away the two
pawns and hand wipe a legitimately good
position in the end game we want to
challenge uh gambits like this in
principled fashion and so the move that
I am recommending is Knight to F6 this
is of course uh a very popular response
that to the Danish we bring our Knight
out we attack the pawn on e4 and your
first reaction might be wait a second
didn't you just say that uh the move
Knight F6 should be avoided in these
types of positions so it should be
avoided if white has a knight on C3 and
that is the chief difference almost
forced is the move E5 you're going to
encounter this move I think in 95 of
your games of course white has a couple
of Alternatives I looked at really bad
moves like Knight D2 which is obviously
Ultra passive and here you can give back
one of your pawns with D5 and then put
your Bishop on D6 white has zero
compensation for the pawn here I also
looked at the move Knight to C3 and here
also you can give back the pawn with D5
so this idea in general is really really
good it's just you don't want to play it
prematurely and here the point is if
white plays Knight takes D5 you trade
Knights on D5 and you open up this very
nice check on B4 then you chase the
bishop away with C6 and Bishop takes F7
check just doesn't come with the same
effect anymore because here after King
takes F7 notice that the queen is
defended white can win the bishop back
with Queen B3 check but When the Smoke
Clears black has a very very nasty check
on D3 this forces White's night out to
E2 and now we bring our Rook over to D.A
there are some beautiful tactical ideas
uh in this line
uh so that's why I ultimately decided to
recommend D5 and one of them is after
Queen takes B7 check here the best move
is Knight D7 which flat out leads to a
winning position because there's the
threat of Rook ABA white is just totally
paralyzed here white can continue
grabbing pawns but after Rook ACA the
game is totally over because the Rook is
getting to C2 but if you want to be cute
if you want to be cute you can also play
the move Rook to D7 unfortunately this
doesn't win the game on the spot
although it maintains a much better
position but after Queen takes A8 you
have a really really pretty checkmate
with uh Queen D1 and Rook takes D1
unfortunately white can play Queen
before and this staves off defeat
because the queen can block uh a check
on D1 with with Queen's E1 so if you
want to be objective here you want to go
Knight D7 and white is completely busted
uh but you know plenty of uh plenty of
cute tactical tricks for black as well
as for white in the Danish so Knight to
C3 can be very effectively met with D5
if white takes with the pawn I mean this
is never dangerous because now the
bishop has been taken out of commission
and you almost always meet e takes D5 by
putting your dark squared Bishop on D6
just to make sure the white can't
re-sacrifice the d-pawn and open up the
diagonal and this position is you know
clear without much analysis we bring the
bishop out to G4 and black has just an
overwhelming position up upon an
excellent development
Knights C3 is not dangerous Knight to D2
Knight F3 uh similarly not dangerous we
deliver a check on B4 and if white
continues developing nonchalantly then
white has just allowed us uh to get our
King out of the center and after White
Castles we can actually take the third
Pawn with Knight takes C4 yes white has
this development Advantage but three
pawns is way too much of a price to pay
uh for measly compensation white is no
tactics here Bishop G7 doesn't work
because our Knight drops back to F6 at
the end of the line and after the bishop
moves back we get our Knight out and uh
it's not hard to see that white just
doesn't have any Targets there's nothing
to attack after something like rookie
one Knight F6 Knight G5 looks scary but
we intercept the bishop with D5 and the
line goes on here we have the very
powerful move Knight to G4 uh
sacrificing H7 and much like in that
Knight takes C3 line we have Queen to H4
which comes at the worst possible moment
for white forking the H2 and F2 pawns so
this is not scary and if white takes on
H7 uh with the bishop then our King uses
the bishop kind of as an umbrella the
Knight on G5 is hanging and if white
defends it then we would want to start
here with a move Queen to D6 attacking
H2 inducing a weakness and now we play
the move F6 this wins the game on the
spot because white is unable to save uh
both the Knight and and the bishop white
has to sack the Knight and remember that
you can use the D5 Pawn as a blockader
you can push it to D4 at the right
moment in order to block the dark
squared Bishop so for instance if y
drops the bishop back and you reach this
position White NOW threatens Queen H5
check followed by Queen H7 Checkmate and
you can't block the check because that
Knight can be captured this is a perfect
opportunity to play the move d4 this
shuts down White's attack immediately
because now the check is safely met with
Knight H6 white doesn't have Queen takes
H6 and You're Gonna Play Bishop G4 on
the next move and repel what remains of
White's initiative so you're not going
to face any of these moves with any kind
of regularity but it's worth knowing
what to do so a knight C3 and Knight D2
can be met with D5 Knight F3 can be met
with a check on b4n so now we get to uh
the fun part we get to E5
here you respond with a check on B4 this
is a compared to the sort of more common
D5 and like Knight E4 this is a pretty
rare Move online and what I love is that
in the vast majority of games that
feature this move white responds with a
line that I can only call losing it's
not an exaggeration to say that the vast
majority of lot of games enter a line
that straight up loses for white on the
spot what I like about Bishop before is
that it poses white with an immediate
dilemma white basically has one two
three four viable ways to defend against
the check I'm not going to look at Queen
D2 I'll let you analyze that on your own
so why does the following options
there's King to F1 moving the king away
there's Knight to C3 which is by far the
most common move and this basically
loses on the spot we'll get to that in a
moment there is Bishop to C3 which is
the least common of all the reasonable
ways to block the check and yet it is
the only way for white to preserve a
feasible position why is still worse in
this line but if you are a Danish player
who wants to meet this line effectively
you have to play Bishop C3 in every
other line Black's Advantage is nearly
decisive and then of course there is
also Knight T2 which is the second most
common move after Knight C3 this goes
down in very similar fashion so let's
tackle these moves one by one we're
gonna end with Bishop C3 because it is
the least common move I'm not trying to
hide the best move from you I will show
you White's Best Line uh and even there
white gets woefully insufficient
compensation for the puns but at least
the position remains a little bit more
combative let's start with the exciting
part why does Knight C3 lose so a
crucial part of black strategy here is
to make an important move in this
position you might say well the Knight
is hanging we have to move the Knight
let's go 94. 94 is a bad move not
because of Queen D5 but actually because
if Bishop takes F7 super common resource
in the Danish we've come across this
move already and white is able to pick
up the Knight with Queen take Queen D5
check Black's King is going to be in a
lot of danger so don't go 94 don't go
Knight G8 What is this hidden move which
a lot of players greatly underestimate
another good opportunity to pause the
video by finding this move you're going
to really chisel it into your memory
you're going to make sure that you never
forget it again so I'll give you the
opportunity to do just that black to
play and completely neutralize White's
initiative this is a move that you
should kind of know instinctively if
you've studied the theory of an opening
like the scotch gamut and the scotch
Gambit white plays Knight F3 Knight C6
Bishop C4 Knight F6 now white plays D4
now the traditional Italian of course is
D3 or Knight G5 D4 he takes D4 and white
pushes the pawn through to E5 and
Black's main response by far is the
counter strike in the center with D5
counter-attacking the bishop on C4 and
opening up Pathways for uh black Bishop
on C8 and this is the exact same type of
principle we dial it back to the Danish
after CB Knight F6 E5 Bishop B4 Knight
C3 we do the exact same thing we push D5
and by doing so we completely neutralize
White's play in the center this move may
seem to lead to a lot of chaos but in
fact it wins the game very very cleanly
and here's how
after the move e takes F6 we do not take
on C4 this is what most people expect
white players get excited at this
because the pawn lands on G7 the Queens
are traded and the black king lands on a
very awkward Square no no no we avoid
all of that with a 10-foot pole instead
we play Queen takes F6
and look at this White's two minor
pieces the Knight on C3 the bishop on C4
are both hanging and white doesn't have
any ways to defend both of them at the
same time if white throws in a check on
A4 not dangerous at all due to uh the
move Knight to C6 and white is back to
square zero if white delivers a check on
B5 we respond with C6 in fact Bishop B5
is the only way to really Stave off the
game although it's almost never played
Black's gonna recapture either the
bishop or the Knight we're gonna keep at
the very least an extra pawn and a
superior position so for instance after
Knight E2 we play C takes B5 then we
develop our Knight to C6 notice that
there is no effective Discovery against
the black queen if white plays Knight
takes D5 we take the bishop we we do not
fear the check on C7 because When the
Smoke Clears our pieces are so much
better developed we just Massacre white
on these open files and diagonals F3 our
Bishop drops back to E6 and F after Rook
to d8 White's just going to lose the
Knight on E2 and with it uh White's
going to lose the game
immediately so that doesn't work uh what
else is there there's the move Rook to
B1 which has been played online and we
just completely ignore the threats by
castling and after Knight takes D5 Queen
H4 black has retained two extra pawns
and white has virtually zero
compensation if white takes on B4 of
course we recapture with the knight uh
and Bishop A3 is calmly met by A5 uh and
making sure that the Knight on B4 is
safe there's not much to say here black
is just two pawns up on the queen side
and White's compensation has evaporated
entirely Knight ef4 allows us to drop
our Bishop back and hear similarly white
has nothing going for him uh on on the
king side and we can solidify the bishop
by playing B6 so Bishop B5 relatively
best but still not very effective other
moves that have been played on line 92
is of course very common in here once
again we take on C4 then we Castle so an
important pattern is that there's almost
never an effective Discovery because the
bishop on B2 is unprotected and once
again if white tries Knight D5 and then
Rook B1 then we drop our Queen back
we're already up a piece so we give the
bishop back up and we're just completely
and totally winning here here black is
up actually three pawns so there isn't
much to talk about if white plays Knight
takes C7 this is laughably innocuous we
can win the game in a variety of ways we
can play Bishop G4 drop the bishop back
notice how we're inducing the move F3
and yeah congrats you've taken the Rook
but just look at what's going on on
White's side of the board we're winning
all of White's pieces we're pinning and
winning and skewering absolutely
everything not much to talk about here
either in the uh file I look at a couple
of other moves here but suffice it to
say that there's really not much to
analyze and the best piece of news is
that Queen E2 check is the most popular
move I've already said the words loses
on the spot the computer evaluation here
is around plus 1.5 plus 2 which is
borderline decisive after Queen E2 check
by far the most common move it's around
plus five because this allows Black's
Bishop to come out to E6 this merely
throws more oil onto the fire now white
can't even put the Knight on E2 so
there's no good way to defend the Knight
on C3 most people desperately Play
Bishop takes D5 of course here we take
the Knight with check and the game is
over a lot of games ended this way The
Rook on A1 is lost with check if White
Castle's Queen side well that is pretty
pathetic as well after Bishop takes C3
Bishop takes B5 the simplest approach is
just to trade all of the pieces on B2
trade on D5 bring the Knight out and
white is up uh White is down two pawns
for absolutely no compensation in the
end game so this is you know this gets
me excited because this is just so
incredibly common online and it
basically loses on the spot just to
rewind a little bit in this position of
course e takes F6 is not forced there's
also e takes D6 but this makes very
little sense because black just
recaptures the pawn and that's it
White's compensation is totally gone the
only thing I'll point out is that Knight
to C6 here is a nice move this is a
pattern that you may have noticed giving
up the F7 Pawn is very typical in these
Danish Gambit lines because white is
often struggling with a lack of
development so the bishop on F7 becomes
more of a liability than a strength
after 92 Knight A5 there you go the
queen is Sever the connection between
the queen and the bishop is severed and
black uh picks up the bishop with uh
just a a completely winning position so
e takes D6 makes very little sense some
other moves are analyzed in the file but
I think that's enough on Knight C3 if
Bishop B5 check occurs here then black
didn't play either Knight ft7 or the
simplest option is C6 this will
transpose into uh the line that we've
already looked at after ef6 Queen F6
remember this is where we were looking
at Knight at 92 and then C takes B5
followed by castling kingside and so
that ladies and gentlemen is the most
common move Knight to C3 is simply met
with D5 the second piece of good news is
that Knight D2 the second most common
move leads to uh similar types of
positions here we still play the move D5
and in contrast with Knight to C3 after
he takes F6 we don't have the option of
taking on F6 obviously here we do take
on C4 and we do allow White's Pawn to
reach G7 but that pawn is a lot less
scary than it may appear The Rook on G8
is a very secure blockade or it can't be
chased away and of course the pawn on G7
is a weakness black is threatening the
move C3 and we have for goodness sakes a
four on one on the queen side and that
is just completely and utterly
overwhelming White's Pawn on G7 is far
from sufficient compensation for the
material losses so I analyzed this
position in detail Rook C1 is the most
common move if white develops
nonchalantly then he walks right into C3
notice that a check on E2 is never
dangerous because we bring the bishop
out to E6 so that doesn't help some
people have tried this here we can still
play C3 and if white plays the sort of
cute C Bishop C3 and Knight E4 then uh
well that ain't gonna cut it because the
absolute simplest approach here is just
give this bishop away don't bother with
moves like Bishop D4 and this is another
pattern that you should be noticing as
I'm showing you these lines here you
pick up G7 with a completely winning
position in the Danish white often
sacrifices so much material that there
comes a point where the best strategy is
just to sacrifice a little bit of it
back right if you're up a piece on three
pawns give away the piece and make sure
that your king is safe that's a much
more practical approach than trying to
cling at all costs to all of the
material
and so Rook C1 is the only feasible move
here we bring the Knight out to C6 and
this is another case in point we give up
the pawn on C4 and we do that in order
to gain our own lead and development we
bring the bishop out to F5 the bishop
threatens to sink its teeth uh at a
opportune moment onto D3 white has no
choice but to continue developing uh if
white plays Queen E2 check this merely
plays into Black's hands the end game is
obviously uh completely one-sided and
here we still deliver the check on E7
white is no choice now but to play Queen
E2 because King F1 walks into uh the
fork on D3 or blackad even Castle
immediately that's even better and after
Queen E2 we Castle we trade on our own
terms we get our King to safety and
after the queen trade All That Remains
of White's initiative is this Pawn on G7
and we are going to surround that pawn
at our convenience so for example Rook
F4 not dangerous we drop our Bishop back
our Knight jumps into B4 where it
threatens to move into D3 three and then
it circles back to D5 and at the right
moment we can just calmly play the move
F6 even if it comes at the cost of the
A7 Pawn When the Smoke Clears here
material is actually equal but White's
position is lost because Black's pieces
are so incredibly active we've got the G
file we've got the bishop pair White's
pieces are totally discombobulated the
engine evaluation here is around -2 I
can barely make a move Rook D1 runs into
Bishop C2 rookie one uh runs into well
doesn't run into anything specific but
now we can walk our Rook back to E8 and
contest that file we can do a lot of
different great things in a position
like this and so Knight D2 is without
question better objectively than Knight
to C3 but it does not come even close to
solving Black's problems uh White's
problems after the move D5 and similarly
if white plays Ed then while black takes
on D6 uh with the queen and this is
similarly toothless uh to this line
after Knight to C3 and so two lines have
been covered that leaves us with uh the
two other Alternatives well you guessed
it after King F1 you will never believe
what Black's move is once again we play
the move D5 and this leads once again to
very similar structures if white plays e
takes F6 this basically leads by force
to an end game in which once again white
gets this Pawn to G7 and it's nothing to
fear remember always and always Queen A4
check never scary because we bring our
Knight out to C6 and we simultaneously
protect the bishop and if white goes for
the end game black puts the Rook on G8
and our biggest project here is to
isolate this Pawn from the bishop start
by playing Knight D7 we need to take
away the E5 Square from White's Knight
and if white jumps into G5 we defend the
F7 Pawn if white greedily takes H7 we
slice off the Knight with F6 then we
take on G7 the Knight is going to be
trapped and if white brings the other
Knight out then we put our own Knight on
F6 to cover the D5 Square so there's a
little bit of hot water here a little
bit of turbulence on board but once we
get our Bishop out to E6 White's
initiative Fizzles out and his position
is simply losing I analyzed a couple of
options here one of which is 96 and 94
kind of a tricky looking move trying to
get black to take the Rook on E1 don't
do that because white will take on F6
with check instead we take the Knight
and we bring our Rook over to D.A now
it's time for white to experience some
turbulence and that turbulence is going
to cause a crash black plays B5 remember
we've got a four on one on the queen
side and once the bishop gets to D2 the
game is over because the move C3 is
finally Unstoppable so notice that the
pawn on G7 this entire time has just
been sitting there it's totally
innocuous because the Rook is on a light
square and The Rook from G8 cannot beat
a sludge so conceptually you might
understand that black is much better but
I also want you to understand that these
end games are really nothing to fear if
you memorize just a couple of accurate
moves so finally
so finally and yes I'm wearing different
clothes in this part of the video
because I was recording this video over
the course of two days so you can kind
of adjust your eyes to the new
environment but finally we have to check
uh the best move unquestionably the best
move for white in this position
which is of course Bishop to C3 and it's
important to emphasize that not only is
this the least intuitive of White's
options because the whole point of the
Danish gamut is uh that the dark Squad
Bishop is one of the engines of White's
initiative and here white gives this
bishop away but also it's staggeringly
infrequently played this move is almost
never played when you compare it to the
more common
Knight C3 Knight D2 and King F1 all
three of which are more popular uh than
Bishop C3 in the text file I have some
statistics
um
yeah it looks like Bishop C3 has been
played in only two and a half thousand
games on late chess compared to 40 000
in Knight C3 and 22 000 in 92. so it's
important for me to frame this by saying
you're likely to never face this move
but that doesn't mean you don't uh have
to know what to do against it you
absolutely do a well-prepared opponent
will play Bishop C3 in this position so
what is the idea of Bishop C3 well the
idea is that after the trade you're
taking the sting out of the move uh D5
in fact black can still play the move D5
to liberate uh some of these pieces but
I analyzed this and after EF dcfg this
is a significantly inferior version for
black uh of a type of position that we
already saw so for example in the king
F1 line if white plays King F1 we know
that we play D5 and if you look at this
end game here the Knight is not
developed here Black's Bishop on B4 is
controlling critical Square so this is a
really really bad version version of
this end game for white whereas in the
bishop C3 version that end game is a lot
less clear and that is why my
recommendation is to avoid that end game
altogether and to play the very powerful
move Queen to E7 which does a couple of
things it pins the epon making e takes
F6 illegal and of course it guards the
bishop on B4 so if white takes on B4
that would be a very bad move after
Queen B4 Knight D2 the Knight jumps into
E4 and uh black has a major initiative
the line goes on white can take on F7
and then win the Knight back with Queen
F3 but When the Smoke Clears black is
still up what is blackout black is up a
pawn uh and white has absolutely no
compensation the queen trade is coming
next and black and always deploy the
light squared Bishop by fiancaronit with
uh B6 so Bishop takes Bishop is not
particularly good white has to know to
play the move Queen E2 and here we make
a move that you might be very
apprehensive about playing but remember
that white is not all that well
developed both sides have their dark
squared Bishop developed and white just
has the other Bishop develop but it's
not like White's lead in development is
overwhelming and that is why we can
afford to play the move Knight to G8 in
this position that doesn't mean that
something has gone wrong this is simply
part of the analysis the Knight is just
redeployed you're dropping it back to
its initial Square yes but you're going
to redeploy it onto H6 which might seem
like an awkward square but from H6 the
Knight is basically unassailable it
controls some of the center it can jump
into F5 and we quickly finish developing
our other pieces remember that black is
up to entire Pawn so it turns out that
white is not able to develop fast enough
to punish black for our temporary lack
of development so the line continues
Knight F3 we redeploy the Knight with
Knight H6 White Castles and this is what
almost everybody does we Castle as well
so we simply keep the tension on B4 and
here I checked a couple of different
moves the most common move is Bishop
takes before if white plays A3 and tries
to trade on his own terms at this point
we are happy to take on C3 and we play
the move Knight C6 and we're gonna get
almost exactly this position in fact we
are going to get exactly this position
through a slightly different move order
the same thing happens if white first
takes and then plays A3 we drop our
Queen back to E7 and here we get exactly
the same position and here it's
important that we simply continue our
development we are not fearing the move
Knight to D5 and Black's idea in this
position is very simple we need to get
rid of the E5 Pawn if we can get rid of
this Pawn this Pawn signals the last
vestiges of White's initiative so if we
can trade that pawn off with the move D6
black is likely to Simply emerge with
two extra pawns for no compensation so
if white plays a move like Rook fv1 then
of course we take the opportunity to
play D6 and here I analyzed this
position extensively but by and large
black is already much much better so the
most sensible move is Knight D5 we drop
Queen back to d8 and now no matter what
white plays rookie D1 Rook fe1 it
doesn't matter your response is one and
the same it is the move D6 which frees
up the bishop on C8 and tries to get rid
of the Pawn on E5 of course if white
acquiesces to the trade then white
basically has no compensation uh for the
two pawns and we're chilling so White's
best move is the immediate Rook 80 one
now we can still develop our Bishop to
E6 but this move is not quite as
effective because of this weird Knight
F4 move so my recommendation here is to
deploy the bishop all the way to G4 in
order to put even more indirect pressure
on the E5 Pawn white basically has to
take on D6 and we take back with the
queen this is another important move to
remember because this line it's pretty
narrow so you're actually quite likely
to get this position C takes D6 is
possible but I like this move more uh
because it sets a trap and it solves all
of Black's problems if white plays
Knight to B6 which may seem to be the
biggest flaw of the move Queen E6 let's
see if you can pause the video and
figure out the stunning tactical
response which enables black to keep our
two extra Pawns
so hopefully you were able to find that
the move is Knight to D4
we're intercepting the attack on our
Queen we're simultaneously attacking
white screen with check and after Rook
takes D4 Queen takes B6 that's it we are
fully out of the woods and we have two
extra pawns notice the role played by
the Knight on H6 which supports the
bishop on G4 and worth threatening Queen
takes D4 in this position so Knight B6
is not good if white plays H3 which is
the computer move then we trade on F3
and we play the cold-blooded Rook a qe8
again there are simply no effective
discoveries it's jarring to play a move
like this but it turns out the white is
no discoveries Knight E7 check seems to
win the queen but again after Rook takes
E7 black wins the game because you snap
off The Rook on E1 and The Rook on D6
and black just gets an overwhelming
amount of material for the queen so that
doesn't work the line goes on but long
story short black is clearly better here
with a couple more computer moves white
can limit the advantage uh to just a
slight Edge but this will involve
another eight computer moves in a row
starting with this move which I don't
think anybody is going to play this is
also already move 20 so we've gone
pretty darn far the upshot is that
Bishop C3 while it is technically the
best move it does not even come close to
solving White's problems provided that
you know a couple of things the first is
this move Queen E7 the second is not to
be afraid to drop the Knight back to G8
uh by the way if white plays A3 sooner
you basically do the same exact thing
the third key is that you're not afraid
of the move Knight to D5 as scary as
this move may appear it's really not all
that scary you can play Queen d8 here
you can also in this particular version
you can slide the queen up to C5 and
then over to A5 and this is an even
better uh version of of this position
but you can also play Queen d8 here if
white plays Knight F3 then after all of
the pieces are developed and white gets
the Knight to C3 you don't play a move
like C6 here you simply get your your
other night out and once the queen drops
back your next move is going to be D6
then you're going to develop the light
squared bishop and from a practical
standpoint I really don't think that
white can demonstrate any compensation
for the two pawns I kind of looked at
this without the engine and it occurred
to me that after D6 black is just in
phenomenal shape and that means that the
Danish Gambit at least in the
traditional way of playing it has been
let's call it basically busted and it
and it's busted by a relatively rare
line
to give you the tldr bird's eye view we
started by looking at the sort of
refined you can call it Danish Gambit
with Knight takes C3 and here you have
to remember to first develop your dark
squared Bishop I've already gone over uh
the small summary of this line so now
let's focus on Bishop to C4 here we grab
the second Pawn we refrain from the
often recommended D5 which is utterly
toothless we start by bringing our
Knight out to F6 we goed white into
playing E5 some other alternatives are
uh examined here as well Knight C3 you
can then strike with D5 but E5 is what
you're going to face almost all of the
time and this check on before this is
the check that a lot of people for uh
forget to deliver the point of this
check is simply to develop the bishop
and then on the next move against all
options other than Bishop C3 we Counter
Strike in the center with uh D5
particularly after Knight C3 which is
the most common move we play D5 and here
the critical thing to remember is to
recapture on F6 this basically wins the
game because it hits two of White's
minor pieces at once we also looked at
Knight D2 here you still play D5 and the
key thing in this line in the king F1
variation is to realize that this Pawn
is nothing to fear because black has
such an overwhelming advantage on the
other side of the board on the King on
the queen side and here black has
threats of C3 we also examined King F1
here as well you play D5 Bishop B5 check
the knight uh drops back to D7 by the
way I don't think I mentioned this line
but most people are going to take on F6
and then go into this end game and again
the pawn on G7 is going to be slowly but
surely surrounded you're going to try to
get this move F6 in and once you win the
spawn uh you're very likely to win the
game and we concluded by checking uh the
best move which is Bishop C3 here as
just mentioned you start with Queen E7
and the rest is pretty straightforward
and that ladies and gentlemen concludes
our marathon examination of the Danish
Gambit I hope you enjoyed this overview
I'd like to remind you that there is a
link in the description to a leecha
study that contains all of these
variations and many more and a lot of
textual annotations so if you've fallen
asleep watching this video and you don't
want to watch it again you can look at
that leeches study and acquaint yourself
with all of the lines at your own pace
but I like doing these videos because I
think for a lot of people you know these
kinds of overviews at least for me
personally I like it when you know all
of the major lines are laid out in
relatively orderly fashion not sure this
was totally orderly uh but hopefully it
did the trick
um so on that note folks I'd like to
wish you the best of luck in busting and
demolishing the Danish in your own games
I will say for those who are still here
that I will be doing a series of opening
videos on uh jababa London lines that
are not covered in my new course the
link to which is also in the description
so you have plenty more opening videos
to look forward to and of course uh the
nerdinsky opening lab series will
continue new and we will bust many many
other gambits thank you guys for
watching and happy Gambit busting see
you in the next video
[Music]